In the 1970s one six foot nine
inch tall man named Edmund Kemper,
towered over his peers and most
considered him to be a gentle giant.
No one in his life could have imagined
that he would murder six teenage girls
hitchhiking through Santa Cruz,
California,
or that he would finally turn
his rage on his own. Mother,
no one in campus life
have a got any bad vibes.
Cindy didn't show him any signs that
there was anything wrong, actually bad,
a genius level Iq ends.
He was the kind of person you could
imagine having a fascinating conversation
with over a cup of coffee.
He was so likable indeed that no one
would have ever guessed that he could be
capable of killing a total of 10
people and defiling their corpses.
He covered his tracks so thoroughly that
he would never have been caught either
until he picked up a pay phone and
turned himself in. Today on biographics,
we're talking about gentlemen Dicamba,
the coed killer.
Okay.
Edelman's Kemper was born in
1948 in Burbank, California.
He was a very sensitive and intelligent
boy. Like many families at that time.
Ed's parents raised chickens and grew
their own vegetables in the backyard as
idolized his father and he loved to spend
time with the chickens and the other
farm animals as if they were as pets.
He gave them all names and played
games with them in the backyard.
His mother was always quick to
reprimands and discipline him,
so he was always a very well
behaved child. He has two sisters,
one older and one younger who received
more love and attention from them about
that.
Ed was still in primary school when it's
fall of the chops to have the chickens
heads off in front of
him. Later, of course,
his mother would cook
for birds for dinner.
When you refuse to eat is pat says
herons challenge and the same over at the
dining table,
forcing him to eat the chicken through
his tears that night he got on his bike
and he wrote as far away as he could, but
he would find that there was no escape.
His father would slowly force him to
get over his sensitivity of watching
animals killed.
As time went on,
he grew numb to the blood and the
headings and he learned to accept it.
This is just a part of life adds.
Later went on to kill a cat.
He couldn't understand why the adults
in his life were telling him the killing
farm animals was acceptable,
but killing a dog or a cat with symphony,
not his parents got a divorce
when he was nine years old,
but his mother was so bitter that she
began to take all of our hatred out on Ed.
She's ads that all men were worthless
and she began to treat add far worse than
his sisters simply because he was a boy.
She moved to Montana and she got
remarried. The second marriage,
it didn't work out.
He threatens his mother went through a
string of boyfriends that never lost it
very long as a male role model, as a
child being raised by now, single mother,
they did not have a lot of toys, so they
would use their imagination instead.
Add rattled lots of books from the
library and is included in his reading
horrific stories from history,
from the vikings to the Holocaust.
He suggested that he and his younger
sisters could play a game called of a gas
chamber.
They tied each other up in a chair just
to see you get themselves out of the
bondage the quickest,
pretending that they were stuck in a room
that was filling up with deadly gas is
another insist is had bedrooms upstairs
and Edwin's had slept in a bedroom
upstairs as well,
but his mother decided to move
his bedroom down to the basement.
She was convinced that he would
hurt his sisters instead of a bad,
he have to sleep on a cot where the
sleeping bag with only a single light bulb
hanging from a string.
It was damp,
cold and frightening with only the
rats to keep him company at night.
According to him,
he interpreted that his
mother has a deeper meaning
behind our actions. He said,
why am I going to the basement?
I'm going to hell that going to heaven.
Ed was incredibly tall for his age,
so everyone assumes that he
was older than he actually was.
He started driving when
he was only 10 years old.
This was totally illegal of course,
but his mother must have allowed
him to use the family car.
One day he drove himself to a carnival
and there was an attraction where people
could slide their head
into a real guillotine and
pretend to have the heads cut
off and soar.
It has a strange contradiction that
people were laughing and squealing and the
face of death just for the thrill of it,
even though it was all just pretends.
Ed Kemper, he got excited and found
himself wishing that it was actually real.
It was in this moment and that is
delusions began to get far worse and he
actually began having
difficulty deciphering what
was real and what was fantasy.
A 13 years old life at home with his
mother became so toxic that he ran away
from home to try and live with his
father runs his new step mother in Los
Angeles,
but the reunion,
which only last a couple of months because
he sent ed to live with his parents
on there,
17 acre farm.
His grandparents lived in a remote
and occasion on the top of a mountain
surrounded by their
massive farm farmlands.
He was completely isolated
from the outside world. Yeah.
His grandmother was just as domineering
and abusive as his mother and his
grandfather. You have dementia
since they lived on so much lands,
his grandparents were to allow him to
use a rifle to hunt rabbits, squirrels,
and raccoons.
His grandmother would carry the guns with
her whenever she left the house for a
year and a half,
things were going fine until edge.
Went back to see his mother for
the first time in almost two years,
she knew exactly which buttons to
press to make them feel worthless.
Being around his mother triggered his
delusions to come back and any progress he
made and his mental health. It was lost.
Upon returning to his grandparents' farm,
he slipped back into a
delusional mental state.
He presented to leave the house and then
he shot his grandmother in the back of
the head with his rifle. Then he
killed his grandfather saying this.
He did not want him to live through
the pain of knowing that his wife was
murdered during a later
interview at Camp said,
but it was a good thing that he was so
isolated from society on the farm because
he was so angry at the
world in that moment that he
knows he would have become a
mass murderer when his delusion was
over reality set in and they'd sore.
His grandparents were
bleeding on the floor.
He could've driven far away from the
scene and no one would have known about
their deaths for an incredibly long time.
But the first thing he
did was called his mother.
He told her what had happened and she
told him to call the sheriff and turn
himself in. So he did. When police showed
up to arrest him, he went willingly.
When he was asked for an explanation,
he owns it.
I wanted to see what it
would be like to kill grandma
since he was 15 when he killed
his grandparents said, can put,
was still considered a minor and he went
to a mental hospital without having to
serve any jail time.
Doctors gave him multiple tests and they
discovered that he had a genius level
Iq and he was diagnosed with
paranoid schizophrenia and can put,
hey actually love living at the hospital
because he was finally getting the help
that he so deeply needed.
He took the proper medication and there
was a lot of structure and stability in
his life,
his mind,
it began to heal and he was fully in
touch with reality for the first time in a
long time.
He was even given a job shadowing one of
the doctors because they believed that
he could get better runs, that he would
still have a bright future ahead of him.
This meant he was able to remain calm
and give the answers that the doctors
wanted to hear.
When they interviewed him,
they weren't convinced that he had made
a full recovery and they set him free.
After four years while he was in custody,
he told his doctors all about the abuse
that he had endured from his mother as a
child and he begged for them not
to send him back to live with that.
It's doctors promised him that this would
not happen and they agreed that living
with her were there any
mannequins mental health was,
but the judge ultimately have
the final say and he bought,
had Camba back into his mother's custody.
Now that he was a full grown adults,
he grew to be a six
foot nine inch tall man.
He was so huge this you have to
dock in order to get into a room.
He spent his childhood being raised by
conservative adults since all of his
teenage years were spent in a
mental hospital so that Ken Burns,
he was shocked to be thrust into the free
love movement and the Hippie Cultural
Revolution that was
happening in California.
He felt very awkward and uncomfortable
and could barely hold a conversation with
a girl. He was 21 years old when
he first went out on a date.
He took a girl to Denny's and a John
Wayne Movie Bus and all felt incredibly
awkward. He didn't smoke, party,
didn't listen to music or go to
parties like most kids of his age.
In the 1960s and seventies his mother
had raised him saying that all men were
awful people and she worked at the
University of California Santa Cruz with
female students.
In many ways.
His mother was a third wave
feminists to truly did despise men.
Having this shoved in his face on a
regular basis made Kemper project is hate
towards his mother, onto other women.
He had fantasies about being with women,
but he didn't have fantasies
about being in a relationship.
It's kind of been decided that he wanted
to become a police officer because
there was a lot of structure and order
in that profession and it would be a good
and steady job. Oddly
enough, there wasn't.
His juvenile record that stopped him
from becoming an officer is rac ought had
been expunged, so it was as if
fitted never happened at all.
It was actually his height that stopped
him since there was a limit on how tall
a police officer be. He decided that
if he couldn't get a job as an officer,
he still wanted to be friends with cops
and he started hanging out with the
police that have arc or the jury room.
He founds a job for the California
highway departments after getting out of
prison and for a short while he had his
own apartment since and independence in
life away from his mother,
but when he fell into financial hardship,
he was stuck living with her again.
They would often get into
intense arguments that made
the situation worse on a
daily basis at drove and drove and drove.
He took out by habits of picking up
hitchhikers and giving them rides.
This was very common back in the 1960s
and seventies and college students held
up signs saying the location of
where they wanted to go in his mind.
Yet this fantasy of killing a
young woman that he would pick up,
he would practice picking up both men
and FEMA hitchhikers and letting them go
free. He did this over 150
times just as practice runs,
say that he could feel prepared
for any scenario at the bar.
He was listening very closely to what
police officers were saying about their
new cases and they mentioned the facts
and this teenage girls runaway over time.
I need to show up sometime later.
In his mind,
he was living out a fantasy where he
would pick up a girl so that he could rape
and murder her. Through all of
these practice conversations,
he figured out what to do in order
to make people feel more at ease.
He also concocted a plan to drop a chap
stick into the passenger door so of his
victims trying to escape. They could no
longer open the door from the inside.
His fantasy was finally realized on May
the seventh 1972 when you picked up to
18 year old girls named Mary and Pascoe
and Anita New Chasa are in Berkeley,
California. They asked for a
ride to Stanford University.
He drove them to a secluded area in the
woods and locked in eater in the trunk.
He stabbed,
strangled Maryann before opening the
trunk and killing a needs in the same way.
Often they would dad,
you raped them and stuff that bodies
into the trunk of his Ford Galaxy on the
drive home.
A police officer pulled him over.
He was able to remain calm
as if nothing has happened.
The officer told him that his tail
light was out and he went on his way.
He laid to dismembered their bodies,
put them into bags and dumped these bags,
models,
pause in order to throw the police off.
Universities in the local area began to
tell the students not to accept rides
from strangers.
They also told everyone that if they had
no choice but to accept a ride to only
get into cars with a campus sticker on it.
Ironically,
as Canva actually did have one of these
stickers from UC Santa Cruz since his
mother worked for the college on September
the 14th 1972 he picked up a 15 year
old girl named Eiko Coo who needed a ride
to a ballet class and he kills her in
the same fashion.
On January the seventh of 1973 he killed
Cyndi shawl instead of disposing of
Cindy's remains like he
had done with the others.
He buried in the yard facing
towards his mother's bedroom window.
Cindy's had was actually sitting in the
trunk of his car when he went to his
state mandated therapy session.
His psychiatrist was convinced that he
was better and they released him from the
court order to continue therapy
even though he kills months apart.
Ed Kemper continued to give rides to young
women on a regular basis just so that
he could get information about what
the public was saying about him.
These women were so unaware
that had Kemper was a murderer,
that they would even have a conversation
with him about this coed killer
speculating about his motivations. He
would hang out at the jury room, bars up,
learn new information about the case.
He also wants you to a lot of crime
shows on TV in order to understand every
possible way that they might
catch up to him. For example,
he had the edge to go to the funerals
of his victims and pay his respects,
especially when he sold the detectives,
so waste drop to the funeral
of a homicide victim.
He knew not to give in to
these natural impulses.
On February the fifth 1973 you got us
into a very intense argument with his
mother and he went out and killed two
more girls, the Thorpe and Alison Lube.
He finally made the connection that the
anger he felt towards his mother was the
trigger that set him off
on this killing spree.
He knew that if he wanted the killings to
stop, he would need to kill his mother,
but this plan would be put on hold.
When the police showed up at the camp,
the residents
a few days on the,
yeah,
the police received a tip that
Ed Canva had purchased a gun,
the Chopin who could see that his personal
record had been expunged and that he
had committed a murder when he was under
18 the shop owner reported it to the
police and gave them add Kemper's name
and address. When the police showed up,
they recognized Ed Kemper from the boss,
so they assured him that it was just
a formality and led them to his closet
where he kept several guns.
Sitting next to those weapons
was a woman's pennys into
box filled with mementos
from his victims,
but for the police officers took notice.
He quickly distracted them and led them
out to his car where he had more hidden
weapons. They did not suspect
him of being the murderer,
but he was very paranoid and he was
convinced that they were onto him for an
entire week. He plant his mother's
murder. When she came home,
it was late and night and edge Kemper
[inaudible] stumbled through the front
door at four o'clock in the morning.
It was at this point that he smashed
her head in with a Claw Hammer,
even decapitated her sexually violated
her face and ripped out of vocal chords,
shoving them in the garbage disposal.
Then he placed her head on the mantle
piece and started throwing dancer
[inaudible].
When his rage subsided,
he realized that he had to
make it look like a breakin.
Otherwise the police might suspect him.
He called up his mother's best friend,
Sally hairless, and said that he
had made a dinner for them both.
When she arrived,
he strangled her.
He then stuffed their bodies into a
closet and left a note for the police.
After killing his mother, the torment
stops. He packed his bags and drove far,
far away.
He was able to actually start speaking
to women without fantasizing about
killing them because the source
of his anger, it was gone,
but he realized he couldn't live with
the guilt any longer and he actually
wanted to stop hiding
and pay for his crimes.
If found the nearest payphone to call
and confess that he was the coed killer,
he waited patiently there for
them to arrive on the ride back.
He gave the police officer's every little
detail of his crimes and the police
officer's felt sick from listening to him,
but he was in custody at that openly
admitted that he could not control these
delusions that had taken over his mind.
He begged for a lobotomy so that he
never had the urge to kill anyone.
Never again. That's, that never happens.
He was sentenced to 10 counts
of first degree murder.
He is still alive today
that he's currently spending
life in prison and his time
behind bars.
He has shown a sense of remorse for his
crimes and he gladly assisted in the
research on the psychology of serial
killers only agreeing to video into audio
interviews.
He also began to teach classes and
computer literacy to fellow inmates and he
has since spoken very eloquently mean
has even started reading audio books for
the blind since he was always so
polite and on his best behavior.
He was allowed to leave prison and to
live in a reform hospital. Psychiatrist.
See, listen to the tapes of Ed
camp, but describing his life.
Believe that his mother must have had
borderline personality disorder or it's,
if it were not for all of
the abuse that he endured,
he would never have
become a serial killer.
Other say that he was just
born a sociopath and that
killing it meant nothing to
him.
They believe that any sign of guilt or
remorse is simply just for show because
it was so good at studying
real human emotion.
No matter what the truth behind Ed camp,
his mental state may be,
none of it justifies what happened to
his victims and it will never bring back
the lives of the women that he kills.
If we can learn anything
from the story of Ed Kemper,
it's that we never truly know what goes
on inside the minds of the people that
we see every day. You just might never
know that that kind man next door,
there's a serial killer, so I really
hope you enjoyed the video. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos several
times a week, so subscribe,
hit that notification bell. You'll
find out all about those and as always,
thank you for watching.